hiatus wallet in my name is Hassan and
I'm just calling about it
I have the Sun for years old and almost
right now for the four months since a
and I know still be there with that I
Billy I'll be giving the insulin or the
one for the nighttime and one two one
for the daytime controlling them for
their well they chew body can will stop
stop there for a minute how do they
diagnosed him as type 1 diabetes or type
2 diabetes type 1 okay time for one okay
any other issues is they have any asthma
respiratory problems and these skin
palms and the eczema dermatitis anything
like that no we don't have anything
no skin problems or respiratory problems
yep okay no does he have any belly palms
constipation diarrhea gas because he's
complained about his belly hurts mouth
okay good
how much does he weigh Hasan 34 34
pounds okay and all right what's his
first name what's your son's first name
yeah I'm you default okay what okay I
didn't quite get the pronunciation but I
believe you okay
all right Charmaine you there okay
here's a 34 pound four-year-old who has
type 1 diabetes what would you do for
him you know we can't reverse type 1
diabetes if it's truly truly type 1
diabetes this is a birth defect
mama was missing something when the beta
cells are being formed in the Alice of
Langerhans pancreas don't have enough of
those does not produce enough insulin
and so he has to have an outside source
of insulin usually by injection and this
is a lifetime deal however was one of
our programs he can actually do better
than just with insulin you know I have
to change his diet a little bit we have
to give him supplement program he weighs
34 pounds what would you give him as
and program to support meheecan dune in
other words we might be able to reduce
his insulin needs by injection we can we
can reduce that significantly whether
it's thirty percent fifty percent or
ninety percent we don't know yet but
certainly we can reduce it okay again
his son is four years old thirty four
pounds has type one diabetes what would
you do for him well for his issues I
would get him a healthy blood sugar
packed and split it in half and give him
a quarter in the morning and a quarter
in the afternoon which to the last two
months okay and then I would also get in
some vitamins III - okay very good
and of course let's get it let's get the
whole household on a special diet no
gluten no wheat bread a rhino's has
maximized the absorption of the
nutrients no wheat barley rye oats no
gluten no fried foods no processed meats
no oils of olive oil coconut oil margins
management cooking oils absolutely no
sugar natural process that means no
juices no fruit
you get everything he needs from
vegetables or so he doesn't need the
fruit and sugar okay Jesus all that's
got to go since he's diabetic and as
char said for two months supply getting
one healthy blood sugar pack give him a
half a dose every day that that'll allow
us then two months and divide that half
a dose into half so you're gonna give
him a quarter of a dose of breakfast a
quarter of a dosa dinner time and of
course a measure his blood sugar and as
often as necessary according to the
doctor's instructions and the odds are
if he's truly a type one you will not be
able to totally wean him off of outside
insulin you're gonna have to give him
injections but we can help him reduce
the amount of insulin he requires every
day and also we can reduce the number of
times you need to stick him every day to
check his blood sugar give us a call
every couple of weeks on let us know how
your son is doing you can start the diet
as soon as you hang up it'll take about
two to five working days to get the
product to you in Arizona